[Musique]
et on poursuit notre émission spéciale
municipal on traverse la région de part
en part les candidats à la mairie de
salins les bains dans le jura nous ont
rejoint ils étaient 3 au premier tour
ils seront 3 au second tour ils sont
trois sur ce plateau
gilbert maire divers droite sortant vous
avez conquis la mairie de salins les
bains pour huit voix en 2014
vous avez aujourd'hui 64 ans également
sur ce plateau michel s'être 63 ans
retraité de l'agriculture divers droite
vous avez longtemps siégé notamment la
chambre d'agriculture départementale
et puis michel bugada divers gauche 68
ans vous avez vous été maire entre 2008
et 2014 d'une petite commune dans le
département du cher
vous avez aussi été directeur des
services techniques
à sanaa les bonjours a tous les trois
merci d'être sur ce plateau alors le 15
mars ce dernier c'est vous michel s'être
qui avait basculé en tête du premier
tour avec vous le voyez 43,2 pour cent
des suffrages 80 à deux voix d'avancé
sur le maire sortant gilbert michel
bugada 21,5 pour cent alors le tirage au
sort vous a désigné michel gala pour
commencer pouvez vous nous dire qui vous
êtes et pourquoi vous êtes candidat à la
mairie de salins les bains
bonjour à toutes et à tous
qui suis-je tout d'abord je suis un
enfant de salins et je suis très attaché
à ma ville j'ai été maire directeur des
services techniques et d'urbanisme mais
je suis un homme neuf
face à mes concurrents qui représente le
passé d'une ville qu'ils ont laissé
délabré et abandonné pour ma part j'ai
une vision fondée sur l'expérience le
dialogue les compétence et l'honnêteté
gilles bd r oui qui êtes vous et
pourquoi êtes vous candidat à un
deuxième mandat
donc bonjour à tous je suis gilbert j'ai
64 ans je suis en couple avec deux
enfants
je suis kinésithérapeute ostéopathe de
profession et par la passion de ma ville
j'ai candidaté il ya maintenant six ans
j'ai été effectivement élu avec lui
voient avance pourquoi se représenter
toujours pour la même passion pour cette
ville et puis surtout pour poursuivre un
projet initié pendant cette mandature
qui est sale en 2025 un projet de
revitalisation transversale qui a été
retenu parmi 300 villes nous sommes que
54 qui bénéficient du soutien de l'état
dans toutes ses dimensions et ma
question c'est que quand je l'entends et
quand j'ai lu les programmes de mes deux
concurrents je n'ai absolument pas vu
reprendre ce programme alors sont ils
prêts à le continuer sont ils prêts à
maintenir la prime d'accueil
la prime pour les façades et la
défiscalisation pour les gens qui font
des travaux
eh bien on leur posera la question
michel s'être qui êtes vous et pourquoi
êtes vous candidat à la mairie de salles
oui bonjour à toutes et tous michel
cents contre 63 cents ou l'avait dit
retraité de l'agriculture un engagement
professionnel important tout au long de
ma carrière
un engagement aussi puisque j'étais
conseiller municipal du d'un petit
village au tout près de seraing où
j'étais agriculteur voilà donc moi je
j'ai souhaité m'engager dans cette dans
cette élection municipale parce que
comme avec un certain nombre de
personnes autour de moi les colistiers
nous avons été très déçus de la gestion
municipale durant ce mandat nous
souhaitons nous mettre au service de de
proposer un projet nous mettre au
service des salinois pour redonner du
sens et de la cohérence
à l'action municipale quoi voilà je suis
entouré d'une équipe très riche de sa
diversité et de ses compétences
alors messieurs salins les bains à
compte 2500 habitants environ
aujourd'hui une population qui décroît
lentement au fil des années que
proposez-vous pour enrayer ce déclin
démographique
vous avez lancé le sujet le meilleur je
vous redonne la parole que faire pour
attirer des habitants à salah et
peut-être pour empêcher qu'il y en ait
d'abord vos statistiques datent elles
sont de 2014 et les statiques de les
statistiques de l'insee ont montré
récemment qu'on commençait à reprendre
quelques habitants c'est sans doute
grâce à la prime d'accueil alors il ya
un gros expliqué la prime d'accueil la
plume d'accueil c'est les gens qui
viennent s'installer à salah en couple
qui ont 1500 euros pour s'installer et
quand il a un enfant scolarisé dans une
école publique de salens et 2000 euros
ce qui nous a permis de recevoir 84 à
peu près nouveaux habitants dont 47 dans
les écoles ce qui nous a permis d'éviter
des fermetures de classes et ça vous
souhaitez le continue bien entendu bien
entendu michel 7
est-ce que récompenser financièrement
les habitants qui viennent qui
choisissent de vivre à salins c'est une
bonne solution
voilà le programme 2025 et à poursuivre
il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas
d'ambiguïté là dessus c'est donc exigé
une bonne chose
c'est un projet tic que l'on que l'on
connaît maintenant l'incitation alors
les moyens d'incitation pour que des
gens viennent et reste parce que c'est
bien qu'ils viennent mais vous aussi qui
reste c'est pas forcément toujours le
cas et aussi quelque chose qui est qui
est recevable qui entendant et vous
quelles sont vos propositions si vous
êtes élu maire avant la semaine
prochaine pour suivre le programme 2025
s'assurer déjà de la situation où on est
aujourd'hui parce que je pense qu'il ya
un moment qui a pas eu de retour précis
voilà pour savoir et selon l'évolution
selon les moyens nécessaires parce qu'il
ya déjà des financements évidemment
derrière et selon ses financements
on fera en sorte que ce programme aussi
kaki et pertinents puisse se poursuivre
michel bugada vos propositions pour
attirer des habitants à salins les bains
pour nous le nerf de la guerre c'est le
logement à salins nous avons 350 400
logements vacants
pourquoi sauter les vacances parce
qu'ils sont insalubres donc nous nous
proposons de créer une régie immobilière
de façon à permettre aux propriétaires
de manière durable avec la commune de
rénover ses bâtiments
comment faire pour ça nous allons créer
cette régie en se substituant
temporairement aux propriétaires pour
monter les dossiers
les propriétaires sont souvent des
personnes âgées vous l'avez chiffrer ce
programme là oui oui alors c'est un un
programme si vous voulez qui s'étale
dans le temps puisque ce serait ce
seront des opérations tiroirs et que on
commence par les bâtiments municipaux
bâtiments municipaux qui sont vides qui
sont en déshérence
donc nous réhabiliterons ses bâtiments
municipaux et ensuite nous logerons les
propriétaires qui mettront à disposition
temporairement par acte notarié à
disposition de la commune et la commune
montre à tous les projets aussi bien
techniques financiers qu'administratif
j'ai bien noté vos propositions pour le
logement vous n'avez pas répondu est ce
que vous maintenez la prime pour les
nouveaux habitants si vous êtes élu
maire dimanche de la semaine prochaine
de la wii de la semaine prochaine
lorsque nous allons faire nous allons
déjà faire un état des lieux général
complet de la vida ressortir tout ce qui
a été fait les études qui ont été
lancées payés par la ville abandonnée et
donc nous allons faire un état des lieux
général qui nous permettra de voir
financièrement où nous en sommes donc
voilà vous ne savez pas gilbert sur la
qualité des logements effectivement il
ya une problématique en la matière à
salins-les-bains quelles sont vos
propositions
alors les propositions se sont bien
entendus avec l'aide de la main des
subventions pour l'analyse et l'agencé
nationale pour l'amélioration de
l'habitat
c'est on ne peut pas aller par la
coercition donc il faut être dans
certains cas il faudra y aller à la
coercition mais il faut aller par
l'incitation le problème de salins et de
l'habitat salinois c'est qu'il y à
quelques grandes familles qui possèdent
beaucoup de logements
les propriétaires sont âgés ne souhaite
pas rénové nou lé successeur arrive ils
sont à la retraite il ne souhaite pas
rénové non plus et c'est comme ça que
bien se dégrade donc là aussi il ya une
forte incitation à voir auprès de ses
propriétaires soit pour qu'ils rénovent
soit pour qu'il vende à des gens qui qui
réaliseront les travaux
ces deux régions je souhaite que
effectivement le fait de la
réhabilitation de ce bâtiment de ce bâti
ancien et est important mais vous savez
aussi qu'il ya des gens comptent des
immeubles là pour défiscaliser donc pas
ils ne veulent pas rénové moi je
voudrais aussi qu'à salins et c'est bien
longtemps que ça n'a pas été le cas je
si si on est aux affaires demain je
souhaiterais que l'on développera enfin
ou viabilisés sera des surfaces pour
pour la construction de puits ce qui en
fait il n'a jamais depuis longtemps il
n'y a pas eu de projet collectif de
construction mais construire plutôt que
rénover les deux c'est pas c'est pas
incompatibles mais mais aujourd'hui moi
je rencontre régulièrement des gens qui
disent m'écouter on vient travailler à
salins et on ne trouve pas de maison
vont concentrer construit j'aimerais
vous entendre sur la qualité de vie les
services à la population qu est ce que
vous proposez pour que les salinois
zélés salluit noah vivent mieux alors ça
peut être en matière de dynamisme
commercial de l'offre de soins michel
bugada alors nous nous souhaitons
développer bien évidemment
l'attractivité de notre ville
comment avec des petites structures nous
ne ramènerons pas des grandes usines à
salins ne faut pas leurrer les salinois
et les salines nous émettrons des
espaces de travail partagés des fab lab
pour attirer de nouveaux artisans
nous avons toute une série d'artisans
d'art qui sont dans des locaux
quelquefois vétuste qui travaillent à
salins qui sont obligés de se loger à
l'extérieur
nous avons un environnement exceptionnel
donc il faut développer l'économie le
patrimoine les termes et nous en
profiterons pour relancer la vigne
puisque à salins ayant il y a un siècle
il avait pratiquement 1000 hectares de
vignes et il reste encore 110 hectares
de vignes en aoc sur ça et michel s'être
sur le dynamisme commercial la qualité
de vie alors qu'à la tête vie plutôt
services aux services à la population
considère que c'est une défaillance
importante de ce mandat
donc nous souhaitons nous rapprocher des
salinois pour développer des services de
proximité pour pouvoir répondre aux
difficultés qu'ils rencontrent d'avoir
un dispositif qui permette de de
s'assurer pour que les us assure que les
problèmes sont réglés
vous avez attaqué les missions en dix
ans nous avons été très déçus par la
gestion du maire sortant
qu'est-ce que vous pointez du doigt se
pointent du doigt c'est la proximité
notamment toute la proximité autour de
faim les services de proximité la
propreté de la ville
l'entretien la gestion des déchets tout
ça tout ça pose pas poser problème et
c'est une vraie difficulté
je vous laisse répondre concernant les
déchets ce n'est plus de la compétence
municipale et d'intercond à chaque fois
qu'il ya eu des problèmes j'ai averti
l'interco j'ai fait remonter les
informations
malheureusement ça ne me suis pas
toujours au niveau de champagnole et du
sictom concernant la proximité c'est la
première chose que nous avons fait quand
nous sommes arrivés c'est de remettre en
état le ccas avec un réseau de proximité
pour les personnes âgées prendre de
leurs nouvelles savoir où elles sont
donc de ce côté là je pense que
on a fait vraiment notre boulot on a mis
25 mille euros par an dans le ccs alors
qu'avant c'était 13000 donc je pense que
là on n'a pas de je pense qu'on a été
plutôt bon temps à proximité concernant
michel il se dit qu'on ne reviendra pas
avec lequel excusez moi ils sont devant
ils sont deux mais celle du canada il se
dit qu'on a eu on n'arrivera pas à
attirer de grosses entreprises moi je
suis désolé j'ai dans la manche un labo
de cosmétiques qui peut venir s'il n'y
avait pas eu le confinement on aurait
certainement avancer sur cette cette
unité sait combien d'emplois c'est entre
30 et 50 ans florent nous des vins et
aux débuts du persil plat
non non c'est entre 30 et 50 nous dans
le développement que vous venez
d'évoquer c'est la maison de santé qui
est déjà sur les rails
du côté de préval et puis pour les
salinois pour les curistes c'est une
salle multifonctions de spectacle qui
sera autofinancé michel bigué allez on
vous a entendu émettre des doutes sur
les promesses du maire actuel
oui une salle municipale de 350 places
et 2 800 m² au centre-ville de salins
les bains qui s'autofinance à dijon le
palais des congrès a beau ne pas l'aider
congrès ne s'autofinance pas je demande
comment monsieur b d'air pourrait
financer une salle de spectacle à salins
avec des fonds propres rapidement à qui
je donne la parole à me salisse à une
régie municipale et des gens que je
connais qui sont prêts à venir
s'investir sur cette salle michel série
sur l'économie sur l'emploi puisque
c'est la question sur l'emploi
effectivement on ne tirera pas
d'entreprises de dimension importante on
peut on peut je pense avec parce que
c'est une compétence intercommunale et
là je jeudi à j-2 bdr que son
application l'implication de son équipe
dans l'intercommunale l'intercommunalité
a été insuffisant loin de très
insuffisant et que l'équipe que je
conduirai sera très présente au sein de
l'intercommunale taux de
l'intercommunalité pour pouvoir appuyer
sur nos démarches de développement
d'entreprise on a une zone d'activités
à salins qui aujourd'hui inaccessible
pour les poids lourds et les bus c'est
une hérésie il faut absolument qu'on
améliore la donc vous améliorez quoi les
voies d'accès où il est en voyage très
rude au delà les voies d'accès est
d'accord j'aimerais vous entendre parce
qu'on sera tous d'accord je pense votre
ville possible non jeu il faut qu'on
avance sur les halls et gilbert
votre villa d'indéniables atouts
touristiques un patrimoine formidable à
valoriser peut-être alors comment faire
pour développer la ville l'attractivité
notamment touristiques j'aimerais qu'on
fasse un tour de table là dessus michel
bugada alors nous notre volonté c'est de
faire de salins la première ville
touristique du jura nous avons 21
monuments historiques inscrits ou
classés contre 10 à arbois 15 à poligny
donc nous avons un patrimoine
considérable qui est un atout
nous voulons mettre en lumière d'une
manière raisonnée les deux forts et les
clochers de nos églises pour avoir un
plan lumière réfléchie avec des
partenaires privés qui sont prêts à nous
suivre
l'environnement des salines la saline de
salins la grande saline de
salins-les-bains est la seule salines en
europe qui est encore présente de paix
moyen âge c'est la seule donc il nous
faut faire des partenariats avec nos
collègues des villes du sel suisses
allemands autrichiens pour faire un
parcours ça ramènera de la tribu de
l'attractivité touristique est très vite
faut conclure nous allons améliorer le
balisage des voies de communication
que ce soit sur les routes les
autoroutes pour venir jusque chez nous
michel s'être vos propositions en
matière touristique car touristique
effectivement le nôtre farce et là c'est
la grande saline clairement alors avec
le célé et les termes à côté mais c'est
la grande saline sur la grande saline il
faut qu on dynamise encore
la l'activité autour de la grande saline
mon repos pour que nous ayons encore des
visiteurs en grand nombre il faut qu'on
développe des des expositions on a
beaucoup d'objets de valeur d'objets
d'art ah ça va il faut qu'on mette ses
objets d'art dans des expositions
temporaires ou permanentes
il y à la maison du par dessus qui est
disponible pour ça qui peut être adapté
sans grands frais dans un premier temps
voilà gilbert a écouté pendant cependant
on a quand même fait beaucoup pour le
patrimoine assez ont fait jamais assez
pour patrimoine mais on a quand même
fait la restauration des murs du fort
saint-andré on a quand même refait la
cheminée de la grande saline
je voudrais simplement dire à michel
bugada que simplement le chiffre pour
remettre en ordre le monument de la
grande saline ses 5 millions d'euros qui
va falloir trouver là j'étais ce matin
avec la drac et ce matin le simplement
l'escalier du puy à gré ces deux cent
cinquante mille euros qu'il va falloir
mettre simplement pour conserver le flux
des visiteurs de la grande saline donc
c'est quand même un gros gros
investissement malheureusement on n'a
pas forcément derrière ce match j'ai dit
que le que le puits l'entrée du puits à
gré n'a pas été rénové il ya deux ans
puisque vous aviez pris la décision à
deux ans vous l'avez repris cette année
faire en 2019 c'est quand même dommage
ans dessus c'est quand même dommage que
ça ne soit pas été fait puisque
aujourd'hui ça limite la capacité
d'accueil de la grande salle guy si on
avait le choix entre la cheminée là et
depuis c'est fini je vais vous demander
de conclure oui ça passe très vite
messieurs je vais vous demander de
conclure michel bugada c'est vous qui
commencez votre conclusion s'il vous
plaît depuis la première heure de mon
engagement dans cette campagne
municipale
je n'ai pas changé mes priorités pour
cela notre prix me notre programme
pardon était et est toujours adaptée aux
crises que nous traversons avec toute
mon équipe nous sommes prêts
immédiatement nous avons des solutions
réalistes concrètes et efficaces pour
faire de salins une ville solidaire
durable attractives et innovantes
ainsi le dimanche 28 juin votez pour le
équipes que j'ai l'honneur de conduire
le plaisir de conduire unissons-nous
pour cela merci monsieur bugada gilbert
votre conclusion
écoutez moi j'appelle les salinoise et
les salinois à nous rejoindre pour
poursuivre ce programme ambitieux de
développement économique de
rassemblement autour d'un l'avenir la
nostalgie ne peut pas être un programme
je leur dirai que au premier tour on
choisit au deuxième tour on élimine et
je pense que j'appelle les électeurs de
monsieur brigada à réfléchir et à voter
utile parce que le maintien de michèle
bugada et bien c'est quelque part faire
favoriser la liste de michel s'être
michels être votre conclusion s'il vous
plaît ggd montrer mes capacités tout au
long de ma carrière professionnelle à
l'engagement à la capacité d'engagement
à la capacité à rassembler je suis à la
tête d'une équipe 100% engagé avec des
compétences je lui ai déjà dit
complémentaires ça nous permettra de
développer un programme ambitieux pour
les salinois dès notre arrivée nous
aurons à gérer la crise qui est la crise
les effets de la crise qui se les effets
économiques en allant chercher des
financements ou partout on pourra pour
réduire les déficits
et puis de toute façon en boule au in
fine et c'est rétablir la confiance avec
les salinois avec plus de proximité et
j'invite j'invite les salinois à voter
pour la liste ensemble
merci ensemble merci michel s'être merci
à tous les doigts d'avoir participé à ce
débat alors il n'y a pas de débat
ce week-end en revanche on reprend nos
bonnes habitudes lundi avec héricourt
mardi belfort lons le saunier mercredi
besançon jeudi de la semaine prochaine
france 3 la chaîne des municipales merci
de votre fidélité dans un instant aux
2,6 l'an pour l'information en région et
puis un gros coucou à catherine aime
syrie on espère la revoir très vite sur
cette antenne bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]